well guys we just watch the Leatherface
exclusive red band trailer yes and you
catch our reaction on that video if
you'd like to see our reaction right
react to review and this is the review
part look at into this we had John as a
man who tends to hail Texas Chainsaw
Massacre the original as arguably your
favorite film one of one of what did you
think of Leatherface origins uh I mean
like this trailer just watching this
teaser you know like it's really easy to
be a little bit apprehensive about a
movie like this so I have no idea how
it's going to turn out but as a teaser I
thought this looked really cool and I've
heard some crazy things about inside and
it seems like they're bringing some of
that uh course filmmaking into here yeah
yeah wish it you know I'm we've done
Leatherface a lot of times local
automakers can be a little more ballsy I
feel yeah yeah they can bring some some
high tension today no yeah Texas
Chainsaw is a series that is hard to get
absolutely wrong for me because there's
something that's just inherently
creeping about the nasty kind of
backwoods II sets they get and the sort
of weird towns folk that are always
populating these movies and stuff I've
only seen one that I just absolutely was
kind of obsessed by and uh so yeah I
don't know I want them to succeed with
this we ran an interview with the dura
the writer a long time ago and he seemed
to be talking an interesting game I
don't love the idea of going back to
teenage Leatherface but uh yeah let's
ruin than the speak a little so on let's
teach you one up his character hardly
scary because you just don't understand
what he's about yeah that works everyone
loves that yeah but uh I don't know I
mean like the version of the story I
heard back then didn't seem like he
couldn't work and you know these images
definitely looked pretty freaky and
pretty intense I'm excited it looks to
be a little bit more in the Michael Bay
produced arena than it does like the OG
Texas Chainsaw Massacre doesn't a few
years ago there's like a Texas Chainsaw
from the original director right
the original driver he just endorsed it
and said that it's the true sequel of a
James Cameron that one yeah completely
disregarding the sequel he directed to
something about this kind of feels like
it might play out like Rob Zombie's
Halloween for me in a way I feel like
you got to commit to one area and that
this is where my concern comes in you
know you got Leatherface origins as if
it's a little baby hello or not baby but
a teenager then you're exploring that
you're seeing his mom and you're saying
oh this kid was always a creep you know
and I enjoyed actually seeing that part
of it and then it seems like it's going
to go into prequel syndrome we're
halfway through it's going to become oh
another typical Texas Chainsaw Massacre
movie yeah some young hot people are
being you know attacked by Leatherface
and being abducted he's hacking them up
I mean you need those elements I know
you need that stuff mean sheriff in town
and it's Steven George it seems like
yeah man let Stephen Dorff yeah I think
that yeah blade so I feel like halfway
through the movie it's been upon it kind
of like what happened with Texas
Chainsaw Massacre at the beginning you
know in a way because that was like a
little prequel then it was more prequel
on the family yeah and it was on
Leatherface I'm more interested
surprisingly in like teenage Leatherface
and his mom then I am in the last half
of the trailer which was giving us
exactly what Texas you can't massacre
was yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I agree
with you I mean the thing is I think
this is all supposed to take place I
think he's going to be a teenager like
though most of the movie at least if
what I read back when is still the case
I kind of agree with you I'm like yeah
at the same time I don't want to see the
same thing I've seen about size before
and this series has been a lot of
different things you know like a lot of
these installments are very different
from one another and it's weird it's
like I feel like you do need some s
stuff like you have to have teens
getting hacked up yeah I know that's
that's what it is but uh but yeah it's
like I don't want this to be the kind of
thing like what bummed me out a bit
about the beginning was like okay you do
this like a couple minutes of like
here's where he came from dorm and a
butcher shop floor
then we just cut to just another
Leatherface of them yeah you know and
that's what I don't want yet like if
we're gonna bother to go back I hope we
make that part of the point that's why I
was referencing Rob Zombie's Halloween
yet because I felt like you know good
half of that movie is an actual prequel
in origin and then the last half is like
out the Halloween movie well that's it
it's actually a good call because I
think he was talking about having this
be like partly he's committed and then
he breaks out or something ah and that
he finds these kids and they are there
like traveling across the guy but in
terms of style this style looks great
yeah it looks different and it looks
like they're actually shooting this and
I'm much more visually appealing nasty
way yeah because if you feel an awesome
sense of really stylized composed
cinematography yeah in these shots I
mean there's some there is some
fantastic shots in here
that are disturbing but cool to look at
at the same time yeah you know and they
have there a number of shots in here
that have a lot of tension without
showing you tons yeah like one image you
know there's a lot of proximity there's
a lot of like guns and chainsaws close
to people's faces yeah yeah yeah that's
just a shot where the chainsaw is really
close to that one guy's face was really
like that's intense that's just sort of
like toying with his food yeah and I
love when killers do that I've done that
before is a little kinky way oh yeah
yeah maybe a lead not sure house well a
Texas I ended up having to wear her Oh
going like well now that I've
accidentally gone this far the other
might as well commit to the bit now yeah
yeah you know you can never you got a
fall on that sword to get commit hard
you know and yeah it's not working you
just got to go with it man and then
rappelling off the drugs wore off I
realized this is what I want to do for
life yeah dark Jojo got very disturbed
well good - Texas Chainsaw video I guess
this is the night as well John that's
the way I operate yeah and then and you
know on the photography one thing I do
like spiritually important is like you
do kind of feel how hot and sticky
everything is yeah and that's something
that always is it
this chainsaw thing that you need you
know here's what I'll say about what I
like from this trailer as well I get
this sense that they might work more on
tension building on this one suspense
and psychological horror as well there's
like that you know that Hitchcock jihads
shot at one point 53 seconds that like
oh yeah shot call were to like zoom it
in but it's kind of zooming it I don't
know what to call that because you're on
Dustin Hitchcock where you push in and
zoom out at the same time you push out
and zoom in at the same time see act
that weird depth of field yeah yeah or
crunch at I don't know I see a shot like
that it's sometimes when I see that I I
assume this director like those kind of
cinematic classic films I would do
angles such as that and it also seems
composing the way kind of how that movie
high-tension was done yeah and the gore
looks a little ridiculous too which I
appreciate you know it doesn't look I
think I'm all for you know realistic
gory grisly stuff at the same time
though it feels a little more heightened
and I feel like Leatherface the the
character is at a point where you can do
that yeah
yeah and I hope the movie got I hope
that the movie matches this trailer in
those spiritual elements that shot where
he shot guns somebody and that blood
blast comes up that looks like real
blood you know like that was I think of
the reaction we both went whoa
you know because yeah like you know the
play of tension and then the release
like that I worked in the trailer and I
hope I bring a movie yeah that tension
and then release yeah pays it compliment
and have following up with a joke it's
all of the shaker is welcome and watch
that guy so I don't know I think that
this could be an entertaining good time
it feels like it could be better than
the last view Texas Chain Saw movie
they've gotten I hope it is I feel like
visually stylistically and tumbly I feel
like in my head even like the music
choice they had over it I'm like that
ironic stuff
yeah like happy-go-lucky old-school
music over violent imagery I love that
eat that stuff I know you're looking
forward to it and I'll be there
regretting going to the theater with you
probably enjoy myself oh yeah yeah I
don't know I think at least as far as
this red band trailer goes I like what I
saw here there have been some uneven
installments in this series but I've
heard great things about inside I like
the imagery here I like their focusing a
bit more on suspense and then when the
blood comes it pops yeah and I hope that
translates into the movie yeah I'm
pretty interested in what they're doing
here so I think it could work I hope it
can work well you guys can subscribe to
the real reject click on a notification
bow good enough official buff good
notification here Lou
John is dead John hungry on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
House calm and as always you can check
out our exclusive perks and rewards over
at patreon.com slash the real R and X
where all contributions go directly to
helping keep this channel alive and
you'll forget some fun stuff along with
it - rizal tree